Hello, good morning everyone.
Good morning, how are you?
Good morning.
How are you all?
Very good.
Sagar sir, have you provided login credentials to them?
I will provide login credentials in a while.
Till then you can continue.
I have already made login credentials.
I will share that in this group.
Sure, sure.
Is the screen visible to all of you?
Yes, ma'am.
The URL for our login is going to be campus.audipay.in
Sagar sir will share credentials with you in the group.
It will be with your mobile number.
You have to log in with your mobile number.
All the work will be done on this URL.
In case the URL doesn't work, we have multiple domain names.
You can change them as well.
One is campus.audipay.
Another one is campus.audier.
You can note it down or share it in the group.
This will be your URL where you have to perform all the actions.
Okay.
Let me show you.
For example, if I open this panel,
this URL will be visible to this platform.
This will be the screen.
Here you simply have to log in with your mobile number.
You will get OTP.
You have to log in with OTP.
The mobile number that you have shared will be there.
You will get OTP on that.
Simply log in.
This will be your first time view.
This is the main entity.
Whenever you log in,
the team will be opened by default.
You don't have to perform any action on this.
This is a common mistake that everyone makes.
You don't have to do anything on this.
You just have to log in and switch.
You don't have to change any details in Team Okidoki.
You can share further details for your entities testing.
You don't have to perform any action on this.
You just have to log in and switch.
If you have any doubts, you can ask at the same time.
Don't have any doubts at the same time.
Or raise your hand.
You will log in and by default team okidoki will be opened.
There will be no action.
You will get this icon on the top.
You have two options.
There are three options.
The first one is Select Entity.
You can switch your entities.
You will be given entities for individual testing.
You will do your daily tasks there.
You will get them.
You have multiple options.
Institute setup.
Institute profile.
Basic setup.
First point.
College.
Basic details.
Further details.
Add it.
School name.
Founding year.
University.
Affiliated.
Social media.
Facebook, Google, Twitter, Instagram.
Address.
Contact details.
Additional facilities.
Institute.
Facilities.
Social media.
Contact person.
With prior information from your reporting manager.
This option.
Confirmation.
Otherwise send MIS option.
Simply details.
Multiple details.
Send MIS option.
Daily report.
In the evening.
Contact person.
Fee collection.
Fine collection.
Attendance status.
Send MIS.
Confirmation.
Normal setup.
That's it.
Website.
Google.
Institute profile.
Sessions.
In case of school.
In case of colleges.
Screen is
Released.
Yes ma'am.
Not yet.
No I'm not yet.
Yes ma'am.
Institute profile.
No.
Yes ma'am.
In case.
First of April.
Calendar.
First of January 31st of December.
Simply.
In the super session.
In case of school.
In colleges.
Our sessions.
25-26 odd.
25-26 even.
It's according up sessions.
Same.
Start date.
Date.
In case.
Wanda.
Simply.
Options.
Future.
Second.
Session.
Edit.
I did connect up second option we use getting a name added connect up first
option getting a next option I'm a pick star is come at the back current may
have got activated session cones I have joe be happy I said just be session go
star career was empty take a jet may be users on this a beat teachers of the
staff members so BK pass by default we will a session open walker so time to
session change up active session be whether not simply a bit by stays be
happy star mark that will be current active session he has entity can there
so I'm a good or is he or Pistachio not going to be miss entity may switch
currently I log in to me because when he will a session open is it clear yes
yes okay next time I pass you have to option a third one is courses kissy be
institute got calm start goodness if I lose my basic cheese I keep my pick
courses got put on a chair you keep courses gave me half pay he up students
cut out a yeah to make up to person go a be client job up go starting up my data
share career toes miss upset Bella set up up courses he cut over courses gave me
half a further Sarah come over he can't feast house but cheeky is course he can't
he's a course in which I get a section so they were so up a course pay he
depended on courses may put I was up which course is pretty fun for that the
courses on a must-have excuse me man I'm just ma'am actually don't say you data
who are you a home client and say could be a game here me I mean team provide
very good name Apple normally yeah that's about to pass client a giant up to
Apple client and say could be requirement share can we put the job up
up on boarding list check list of the onboarding
wash it in a client app or attack put it there okay
I'm gonna make my digital list there have a list a proper list QoT yeah that's
recording Apple client is that requirement share can make him up see
yeah data required a client Apple could they go until unless Apple clients
name in the hood say handover can make you give you up training phase may have
I'll be happy to give me a guy in a fit up to pass with the client a to use case
may up to the job reporting manager or a job you have to lead the rock over
person up for data ranger okay thank you
Apple data pick I'm gonna have to walk the recipe check it to us may data may
have to pass courses that they have school kick this may be who yeah college
kick this may work courses that are top go that I may will jaga I'll be up with
a data name in the top of simply get a next school can you set up gonna have
nursery or the kindergarten classes and up to 10th or 12th courses but I was
may have a basic structure or the head or normally I'm sabi can they follow
cut this cool kick is my way universal raya up to do courses can I'm gonna go
is nomenclature map use correct proper case map class mansion getting a single
space then numeric made one two three four s a piece may Roman counting use
short form use the same common pattern for look at not that you can't be a map
go but I did you have to pass you have to option given a new class car yeah of
course gonna mention getting a dissimilar be up go with that genomic
nature up we use gonna have a year ago yeah I'm not going to be extra space
starting me and me up now you dial a key bar may job up further action
performing a toe up a little bit you do both critical with each other I'm gonna
be extra spaces in a star I'm on when I have a big single space with Anna to
jump up data pick I'm carrying a class one kill you up go home a show us
particular entity get a class on give us face like a channel up at it so I
push be extra need a king a job proper cheese have we've been hanging a course
group up go all rough may have in case I'm goofing the rain kiss institute may
last sequence number up you have to do the sequence number up you have to
mention that I get was sequence map the bus you have to get out of it then lead
course name compulsory name is lead be compulsory name he's got sickers at the
end as soon as one minute was given school the case map on normally up to
10th stream same here at the air to upstream name same racking a agra
because streams cut seeds cut out ahead so up seed cut out a half a free
seeds number of seats up as given a class one minute plus 50 seats at the
walk feel good so there are ways of course keep us at the head or up to
10th class up the streams the same rehingi nursery lkg ukg and then
firstly get an 11 to us map go put a stream so the school's cake is made to
walk up streams can they mention to look at for example may spell out and kill
everybody to make a bus you have the streams are doing a science then again
the classes have abuse for me my love play way be aga she kept to up course
add carrying it over by default Jackie last may I get a gap go up the course
yoga will last me up a 13th number ke baadada but actually that sequence they
go to other student is according for draft re nursery nursery lkg ukg then
one sec one two three four is according sequence so that the courses go
according filter gonna kill you have a database may be a sequence number use
okay okay thank you she can I got up with course last may I get a but I
thought I was starting me the capo to a sequence number will work here yeah
perhaps streams add carrying it's okay but it may be streams of an ad stream
next to mad carrying us ke baad batch school cake is my batch na he hota
we've button he disabled karna hoga boom abhi aqua give it out to me colleges
get case may batch hota is me up mention carrying a semester wise so that the
semester can aim I'm a giant or year wise at the first year second year third
year Ajay clear a school cake is make a baby batch na he hota ye baad dhyaan
Rukhna Hameesha yes me option be me I got your option be up we have a city
she can then further section data may have grabbed the past sections cut that
I have so I'll be happy sections mention carrying a otherwise na he I thought by
default her course can be a single section like a channel that is section
a ticket further up go put a lot key courses can the students go groups may
be segregated at the head he ate quite class house can there have been a child
group of an idea whores of the have a house wise oh yeah poor colleges may
say good students have a fight here on the tone pop out of a good groups we
want to have a group B group C group yeah how to use according to the groups
be segregated na he ha to go groups up we have to be here but a compulsory na
he had a client key requirement a has a tabi apple groups banana otherwise a piece
of this option goes hold it okay simply then up add the clicker in a group
moment nature fixed a like a use going on for that use getting a number will be
fixing a joke line requirement share that up over na which may do a few
groups of the A B C D character okay yeah I've got my MBA course give out
through the MBA a few groups with a good finance the group a good marketing
group pass the woos according banana they are so happy push me fix me up go
sir joe course can name Hannah school cake as me who's gonna make lecture
fix a key a use gonna have a girl koi client was others even got that I can
even a bit of kucho on that was case mappies for change Karengi otherwise
Sabi may have a techie he took time or colleges the case may I like a guy whoo
unca joe be with us a beat up what joe be a walk now share Karengi woes
accordingly again a bad Yanak na joe be up course banana I hope I lay confirm
karke banana course a barge of under a woe delete na he hota she can't for
example I'm gonna say testing on a course banana me a past is the spelling
very good little game I'm gonna go small made out of it mojo's go proper case
Madonna to other course can the kucho be change gonna add to my second option we
use karungi to my passable course open a good name freeze are my further details
change got something but is going to change got something I'm going to stream
a kucho be changes karna to my fancy I can pick like karungi changes karungi
and then what we say for the other my exact name he got a course that was
given it was first of all option as in a course name at it because he can course
or so some of the banana a kicky course banana a bar delete na he won't get or
push is gonna hacky app which be extra space starting me yeah ending me now
like it's a is it clear kissy Kobe courses may kuch be down though man why
given sequences number same to two classes like class one in class must be
have to say testing entity has a person's task perform got a kucho be
test karna okay okay usually sequence wise he'll go within a starting
you can institute profile session creation and courses you see no points
up a clear yes ma'am she can escape I do compulsory field
rehingi Indian okay bad up to pass over a gas student fields here up to pass
option kissy be student cadaver up to ERP mr. karna to palipa up to pass
options active on a cheeky is kiss fills me with a data down and up to the
top data need else the word data graph or down at the top student field
selling it because I've got my kissy fresh and fresh as my back a little
push me I just see a piss go open carrying a will pull fresh session may
do you have to do you have to pass data that push me I got up to pass the
simply a button I get though the screen pay so I'm off with the father take
a session when I came in this is a shaman I'm the jigger page refresh
karna pedega talk to me about drop down may I even those are the fish can I'm
sitting on session so I'm a check for me that I see a lot of session you have to
add when is good as a switch here so I'm up to go this may to me I will say
up to pass drop quantity me they give us a thousand me option I keep fresh me
up to have you one time set up with that was given up to set up me gonna
get up the bus you put about the option here you have to put a screen piece if
you know options visible on this may at the add new fields got your click here
to apply default or save up go for a larger action perform karna I have a
click here to apply default Jesse he's button that click career push basic
filter that is a job to be on the screen pay you automatically have to pass our
information I do with the kids to store karna but my bus could fill in a house
name come to me for example left reason leah or joe be what detail for example
I'm home but check I'm on the tanky home it may but Jenny up the sports may
certificate attain can't switch as a data store can make this institute to
sport certificate
you can't miss for display name you do me yeah like an actual me my age of
client is data code a cap and a student to data code the only field can amy a
decage sport certificate count or is can the joe value I'm gonna tell you you give
all the key top kissy be student field core rename curse at the way I say clear
Jobe happy happy fields capture cut them up go but I did you will feel so you
have to be student listen to me kissy be student cop and get it got you up go
so it's truly yoga man actually in starting if we are a multiple yes yes
in starting when we are implementing a new institution and then we are adding
some students so we have to manually add all thousand students or so how we are
know first of all other up to see client implementation become career to up go
one-time data important not the host about her session major admissions with
a more client and become with us map okay so that will assist her not that
will be sure that I'll go man will need on the put it second is job you up
implementation that I'm gonna come in here you have to ask bulk my data to
her cheese get my bus bulk import option given up go excel miss sample my data
So understand, like in starting, we'll pass an exit sheet format, the pre-format of our
company to the institution.
We'll pass it to the institution, the institution will fill all the data of all the students
and then we'll import it.
Yes, yes.
We'll make it our coding, format it and import it.
We have a bulk option for everything.
You don't have to do anything manually.
We have a bulk import and bulk delete option for everything.
In case you also have to delete data, then delete it in bulk, don't delete it single
Done.
Thank you.
In the case of this student, there is no library, there are admissions, and the data of fees
and receipts.
We have a bulk import for everything.
Now I'll tell you, we add some basic student fields from there.
As I told you, there was a click-array-apply option.
I'll show it to you again.
In the student fields, if you have a bio-default, then you have to click this, then click this
and simply save it.
If you want to add something, then you can add it from here.
Which field you want to take, what display name you want to keep, that's your choice.
According to the client, hide.
If you want to keep any field, then hide it, meaning you made it, you don't have to show it to anyone.
So you can hide it from here.
If you don't want to hide it, then you'll keep it low.
After that, which group will it show in and what type of field it will be.
That means it's text type, drop-down, file, everything.
So whatever these fields are, how they are visible, I'll give you an overview in the student's profile.
So that you understand a little.
The fields we made there, those fields will look like this.
The child's name, date of birth.
The name, we gave it a display name, student name.
So that's what's written here, student name.
In that, the data is showing.
There was an option to buy a group.
If we write personal details in it, then all the names of the groups, personal details,
you'll get them all in this same group, summed up.
Is it clear?
Yes ma'am.
When you do the rest, then it will be more clear.
As you do it slowly, you'll start to understand it.
Student fields, you understood.
I told you four options.
How to make the profile, how to add the session.
Courses, setup and fields.
Is it clear guys?
Yes ma'am.
I'm telling you one last thing.
Some basic setup that needs to be done first.
That is institute preferences.
The first option is color.
You can set the color theme according to your client's logo.
Here you have multiple options given.
Whatever your client is, you can change the color theme according to it.
You can set those preferences here.
You can also simply save it.
Next option comes.
First of all, you won't need it.
Because when you get the entity in the starting, then you get the color according to the logo.
In case the client also puts the requirement that I don't want this color theme.
I'll show it in some other color.
Like now you can see all the blue-blue for this entity.
If I switch to some other entity and show it to you, then its logo will be of some other color.
The theme will also change.
Some will have blue, some will have red, some will have green.
All the fonts will look green.
Next option is fees.
I'll show you the fees here.
Here is the profile view of the fee.
It should be horizontal, vertical or fee head group wise.
You can set that from here.
Horizontal, vertical, fee head group wise means you will understand when you cover the fee section.
When you go to the fee section, there is an option to collect fees.
You can set the view of this profile, horizontal, vertical, etc.
When you do the fee section, then it will be more clear.
I'm just telling you the set part.
You can set the view of the fee profile.
Whatever you set from here is universal.
All the users of that entity will have the same view.
The second option is library, book, security and fine collection.
How do you collect the library book's security from the student?
The librarian will do it in the library.
The library will be separate.
Or the fine will be added to the fees.
The fee department will collect it.
There are two options.
If it is separate in the library, then you will choose the library.
If you want to include it in the fee, then the librarian will transfer it to the fee.
The fee clerk will collect it.
You can set the options for library, fine collection.
When we change the formatting, like horizontal or vertically,
or in any other aspect,
then it changes dynamically according to the web and app.
It is manually separated for the web and for the app.
The setup part is only in the case of the web.
The actions performed are mainly performed from the web.
I will tell you about the fees.
You can never perform the fee action from the app.
The client will also perform it from the web.
He will collect the fees only on the laptop, PC or computer screen.
He can never collect the fees from his phone.
There is no difference in the fee profile because it is normally for the web.
All right, Manu.
You can always do the document compulsory.
Whenever you edit the fees, you will have to upload the document.
If this option is on, then the option will be compulsory.
Next is allow separate receipt setting for each session.
Whenever you tick this option, the option will be active.
If it is unticked, then the option will be inactive.
Remember this much.
You will understand the rest of the options only by reading it.
Allow separate receipt setting for each session.
If you want to run different sequences in each session,
like I collected receipts from 1 to 100 in this session,
then I have to run the number from 1 to 100 again in the next session.
In that case, this option will be used.
If you want to carry forward from 100 that the next session will start from 101,
then in that case, this option will be off.
Is it clear?
Yes.
After that, we have some terms.
For example, I don't have to pay the fees for April.
I have to pay the fees for May, leaving April.
In that case, you can skip the first term.
In that case, this is the button.
If you allow this, then you can skip it.
Otherwise, you cannot skip it.
You will have to carry it with you.
Next is allow select session.
You can select multi-session.
If the child has a due for last year or this year,
then you can click on it and collect the fee.
Otherwise, you can do it in this one.
In that case, if this option is not on,
then you will have to switch to session only.
From here, you will have to search and then take it.
If this is on, then even in 5 sessions of that child,
if the money is pending,
then he will give you 5 pop-ups on the screen.
You can simply click from there and take direct fees.
Okay?
I told you that in courses,
there is no batch option.
Do you remember?
Yes, ma'am.
In the case of school, you will keep this button inactive.
You will not tick it.
There will be no batch option when you make a course.
Only in the case of colleges and universities,
you will turn on this button.
In the case of school,
if you are making courses and there is a batch option,
then you know where to switch it off.
From here, you can switch it off
from Institute Preferences.
The next option is
whenever we issue a certificate for a new student,
do we have to check the library's dues?
Is there any book return pending?
If you want to check,
you can do it from here.
If there is no role of the library in the case of new students,
then you can switch it off.
The child has given an extra fee.
You have to adjust it automatically or not.
This is the option.
The system will pass the entry of automatic adjustment
if it is on.
These are the character dues.
This is also the same.
When you issue no dues,
do you have to check
if it is necessary to check the fees?
If the client gives a confirmation,
then you have to switch it on.
Otherwise, it is a normal option.
Next is the fine setting.
Number one is fine partial payment.
In our system,
you set up a fine.
When the date comes,
the system automatically calculates the fines.
If you switch on the option
fine partial payment,
which means
if a child has been fined 100 rupees
when you are taking fees from that child,
can you take that fee as 50 rupees?
I mean,
my child is not currently paying
100 rupees.
He is only paying 50 rupees.
When this button is on,
you can take a 50 rupees fee
otherwise you have to take 100 rupees.
Is it clear?
Is it clear, guys?
Yes, ma'am.
Next is the added calculated amount.
That is the fine system that is calculated.
When you switch on this button,
you can edit the calculated fine.
Otherwise, you cannot edit it.
Otherwise, it will remain fixed.
You will have to take as much as the fine is shown.
These two options are a bit confusing.
If anyone has any doubts,
you can ask them.
No, ma'am.
It is very easy and basic.
When you do it, it will be more clear.
You should know the meaning of every option
if you don't know the meaning of the option.
Because whenever you have
a session
of question and answering,
you will be asked
the meaning of any point
from this option.
Normally, it is self-explanable
points.
Next option is
attendance.
In this, we have three or four
It depends on what the client opts for.
First is date-wise
and method-wise mapping.
This model works
in the case of schools.
Today's data will come in class 1.
I am in charge of class 1. I have marked attendance.
That's it.
After that, in colleges,
institutes or universities,
we have different models.
For example,
lecture-wise employee calendar.
In this, we have date-wise employee calendar.
This is our timetable
or
other than that,
we have open timetable.
When you understand attendance,
then you will understand
for which client you should set up.
In the case of schools,
in both, date-wise and mapping
is the first option.
This is fixed in the case of schools.
After that,
we have attendance version.
In this, we have three versions.
One is the old model.
It will stay with you for some time.
After some time, it will be removed.
But now, many clients are using the old model.
There is a new model
and a version 3.
Some of our old clients
are using the old model.
But if you set up a new client,
you have to use the new version.
Version 3
without prior information
will not be given to any client.
Now, if you want to set up
you have to use the new model.
Attendance version new.
The exact meaning of this
is that when the attendance module
is trained, the time will be clear.
After that, we have the option
HRM leave cycle.
In our ERP,
the staff's attendance
leave will be applied from when to when.
What will be their structure?
All of that works.
So, currently, what is their active leave cycle?
Here, that is visible.
This is not compulsory setup.
When HR is running,
it is updated from there and
it will reflect automatically.
After that, there is an option
that
update after payroll compute.
That
you have to update the setup later.
Next,
allow future date.
that if you want to
allow attendance in future date,
you have to
4 days in advance
of employee.
This means that
you have to apply for
4 days of attendance.
If you have this option,
you can do it. Otherwise,
we keep it disabled.
Because you can't mark attendance in future.
Then, we have an automate feature
here.
The setup you do here
is automated.
Its alerts or data
are automatically transferred.
Okay?
The first option is the automate voucher.
If we automate the receipt,
it is automatically transferred
to our account daily.
Okay?
Similarly, you can automate payroll.
If you automate payroll,
it is attached to the salary
of the employee.
Next, we have analytics.
You can automate it.
You will understand these options
when you study
these options.
Now you don't know what is going
with the exact voucher, payroll.
Okay?
These are all automate options.
From here,
it will be automated.
This is the gate pass.
In the gate pass,
you can turn on the OTP verification.
You will understand the training
for this.
Next is the due fee alert.
If you want to set a timely alert,
you have to send a message
to the kids on the 10th of every month
that your due is pending.
If it goes away automatically,
you can set that alert.
The system will auto-shoot
the messages.
Similarly, you can set the library alert
and add the days.
This is the automatic option.
After that, we have the next option.
Is the automatic option and the attendance option
clear to everyone?
Yes, ma'am.
Next, we have student app preferences.
This
relates
to the student app.
How many PITE students
are there?
Three.
Did you use the Okidoki
Sprint app in your last session?
Yes, ma'am.
You can control
what you see and what you don't see.
From the student app preferences,
you will see your profile,
school diary,
attendance,
fee, examination library.
All the options
are given here.
will be shown on the student app.
All the options you turn off
will be disabled from the app.
You won't see the options.
These are the modules.
You have to show them on the app.
After that,
there is a mapping of the transactions.
You can automatically
pay with the app.
This is not required.
We automatically set this.
Next,
I will tell you
what the fee setting is.
How much can the student pay with the app?
How much will the student pay?
Can the student select a head or not?
You can set that from here.
1. Select a term.
I have to pay for my last session
or for this session.
You can choose a term.
If you want to show the fee head,
you can show that.
After that, if you want
to pay as much as the fee is shown,
you can pay that much.
If you want to do something partial,
you can do that.
This is a different concept.
If you want to do transport,
you can choose transport only.
In that case, you can select the fee head.
After that,
there is a flexible module.
Flexible module means
if I disable it, the option is removed.
It means what you are fixing
the minimum percentage.
If the student shows 10,000 fees,
what percentage do you have to fix
that he has to pay that much?
We have kept 0 here.
If someone wants to try even one,
then his one rupee will be
submitted in the fee.
Some schools say that if the student
pays from the app, he should pay
at least 10%.
Is this point clear to you?
What percentage do you have to fix
that he has to pay that much?
You can fix that percentage
and you can select your session.
If he wants to pay his previous session fee,
he can go there and pay it.
Is it clear, guys?
Yes, ma'am.
We have two small admissions left.
In admissions, you can choose
the by default session.
For example,
admissions for 25-26 sessions
are going on in all schools.
I will call you in two minutes.
I did not go.
Here you have the option
select admissions session.
When you take admissions in the system,
you can see the data of the by default
session here.
There is an active session here.
You can choose that active session from there.
As my 25-26 is going on,
I should only open the data
of the 25-26 by default.
You can choose the setup of that session.
Here you have the current default
session.
Next,
application data approved
auto-generate.
Here you have two options
given.
Either your roll number is fixed.
Whenever you are giving admission to a child,
you should turn on the button
and the upcoming roll number should come automatically.
In that case, you will auto-generate.
If you do not want to give the roll number,
you have to save the number
from which the application came.
In that case, you will use this button.
In that case, the auto-generate button
will not come to you.
We have two processes in admissions.
When you are giving admission
to a student, either you
load the roll number at the same time.
In that case, you will
use auto-generate.
You will set up this option for the entity.
They will set up their own roll number.
When you auto-generate,
they will get the roll number.
The sequence will go on automatically
and they will get the roll number at the back end.
Another one is
you do not have to load the roll number.
Once all your admissions are done,
you will give them the roll number after that.
In that case, you will use the application number.
The number from which the application came
is the same number as the admission number.
The same option is given below.
You have to auto-generate.
You have to warn the admission number.
Do you have to give admission on the back date
or not?
You have to disable it.
I have put the data 4 days before the back date.
I am giving admission 4 days before the back date.
So, you have to give that option
or not to the client.
For admission,
you have to take some fees
like the prospectus fee, or the entrance fee.
The receipt number is also valid.
It will be separate session-wise
or you can set up that here.
Whenever you have any data,
the counselor will compulsory
call that person.
The counselor will compulsory call that person.
This is the option.
Next, we have some things
which we can change the display name.
What I told you was
the student fields.
What we can see here
we can change the display name of some things.
Some things are listed here.
For example, we have
by default, the data of the children
will go to the reg number field.
But some clients say that
we don't have the reg number.
We have this.
So, we can change the name of those fields.
You will know what you have done.
But the client will see
what you have given the display name.
Here, I will show you
some things which are listed in the drop down.
For example, reg number, roll number,
attendance,
you can do the course.
Now, you can see the course.
But in the case of school,
you can do the classes.
You can convert the batch into year.
For example, someone says that
I should write year here.
The same thing is there.
For example, there is a concession.
We are giving discount to someone.
Now, someone will use it as a concession.
Someone will say that we should write discount.
There is tuition fee waiver.
You can change the names.
For example, there is a school diary
which you should know.
Normally, it is called school diary.
In the case of college,
we call it college communication.
Here, you can see a module.
Here, you can see college communication.
If I delete its name
and update it,
then this same thing
will be visible to me in the name of school diary.
There are some options
which are the same.
Only according to the client,
whether it is school or college,
we change the name of the display.
Is it clear?
Yes, ma'am.
Similarly, we have some templates
and certificates.
For example, appreciation certificate
is issued from ERP.
There is an admit card.
There are some which are not useful
They have some other requirements.
We make them according to them.
We make templates.
We simply change the display name.
For us, it is appreciation.
We have made that code in appreciation.
But the client needs
a transfer certificate.
We will change its name
so that the client can see
the name of the transfer certificate.
In this way,
you can change the display name.
Those who can do it,
they are coming here.
There is nothing else
other than this.
This is the viewpoint.
You can change the student field easily.
After changing,
you have the save button
on the top.
You have to click it.
I have told you the meaning
of these options.
When you do it slowly,
it will be clear to you.
You will be able to
interlink everything.
I have seen it there.
This is the display.
It will be clearer to you.
This is all for today's session.
These are basic things.
This is just for knowledge.
This is a 10-minute setup.
Does anyone have any doubt
or miss any point?
No, ma'am.
Everything has been pretty clear.
Yes, ma'am.
Everything is clear.
Everyone has cleared
every point.
Any doubts?
No, ma'am.
Sagar sir
will send you credentials
from your panels.
After that,
you can start
your session
and add courses.
You can explore
all the options
that I have told you.
You can see the meaning.
If you have any doubt,
in the next session.
Ma'am, I want to say something.
Yes.
Whatever training
you have given,
any assignment
or basic
that you want to do
so that I can share it,
you can try it.
I have informed them
so that they can log in.
Whatever you think
is a basic setup,
send it to me
or send it to the
onboarding group.
Okay, sir.
If you have any doubt,
you can directly ask Manasi ma'am.
I think
we are done with the meeting.
Any doubt, guys?
No, not yet, sir.
Perfect.
So, I have shared,
I have added the logins
on to the USR.
You can log in with your mobile number.
Initially, you can log in with the OTP.
Then you can reset your password.
Yes, sir.
I have added few of the institute
and one of the main
I have added is
I use testing.
And there are few others
you can do the changes
or whatsoever you want to do.
You can do whatever you want to do.
Okay.
And if you have any kind of doubt
regarding the same
that you have done in this particular training,
so you can share on the group
or you can directly ask them on Zoom
or you can ping them.
Alright, sir.
Shall we close
the meeting
just a second while you are recording.